great intro hey I was gonna braise -
beautifu today we have a very very very
we have a very special episode we're
going to go through five robots I think
I probably spent more money than I
should have on this episode the things I
do for your brows to be honest I was
just shopping while I was drunk but I
collected five of them so let's review
them the first one is the parrot sumo
then we're going to move up I'm scared
next we're gonna move on to this the
it's not real I promise this one can
shoot [ __ ]
and then the gun free now okay
oh let's go so the point is to find
whichever drone will scare Edgar the
mouse is already scared this is good oh
my god
terrorizing my dog for YouTube you yes
I'm like
I have no idea where this one does it's
pretty cool
I have too many toys it sees its prey oh
my god so creepy
okay let's watch me try fires dance
it looks moves really cool a guy who's
going for good sellout
good job what are you doing Duggan's
illa Hummer
oh my stop he wants them all you can
check them out oh my god shut up I live
a link to in description and that's it
for now you enjoyed this special episode
no firewood stuff online for us I'll see
you in the next one as always stay
awesome is it on whoa whoa whoa oh god
what is going on it's on
okay cool
holy [ __ ] I don't know what's going on I
feel weird